dr. Hansen is a military historian of
some renown as a classicist of equal
renown he is also an agrarian he knows
the soil well he is a man who has taught
at Stanford he is a man who has taught
at the highest levels of academia he is
also a man who has advised Presidents
and vice presidents and as a man who
stands for those essential virtues that
the Roman and Greek worlds have passed
along to us he is often criticized by
the left which makes him a perfect
speaker at Hillsdale Academy I present
to you dr. Victor Davis Hanson
thank you very much for having me very
happy to address the class of 2009 and
the families and friends of that class
I think we're engaged in 2009 and the
greatest change in transformation of
America that we've seen in our lifetime
and it will take all the education and
learning of the students of this class
not merely as is their want either to
oppose or to support that change but
merely to understand it think for a
minute had I or any other speaker been
here a year ago in May and I had said
the following would you believed it if I
had said within a year the greatest
financial institutions in the world will
be bankrupt Lehman Brothers Bear Stearns
goldman sachs teetering if I had said
that Henrik kaiser's once venerable car
company would be bankrupt would you
believe that if I had said that the
president I'd stay will be both the
regulator and the CEO of General Motors
would you have believed it if I had said
the Chicago Tribune will be in
bankruptcy San Francisco Chronicle will
be on the verge of going out of business
and the stock price of the New York
Times will be less than the value of its
Sunday edition no one would have
believed it and yet what we've seen the
last six months is it the cause of this
change or is it merely the effect of
much larger transformations that have
been going on in American society for a
long time the tawdry and the cheap
whether overt ads for sexual enhancement
or advice about intimate personal
hygiene err on our public Airways as
overtly as dog food commercial once
national marque actors are as likely to
dam their country as ignore it when
abroad and when we hear sermons from a
recent American Nobel Prize winner an
Academy Award winner a Pulitzer Prize
winner
we brace in anticipation that the
acceptance speech will be some sort of
damnation of our history and our present
culture of all that we were and all that
we are the politics of your America
class of 2009 is even more confusing
think of this all the old labels liberal
conservative Democrat or Republican
radical or reactionary give way to the
expediency of the moment liberal
President Bill Clinton balanced his last
budgets but raise taxes conservative
George Bush increased deficits but cut
taxes but now taxes spending and
deficits or all at once what term can we
dare invent for that we've been we've
seen housing slumps when home prices
were high and interest rates low or when
prices were low and interest high or
when prices and interests were alike
high but have we ever seen a bad housing
market in which both home prices and
mortgage interest rates were low common
nonsense has passed off these days as
elite wisdom the big spending government
promises that it may cut our annual 1.7
million dollar deficit excuse me 1.7
trillion dollar deficit and half by 2012
but they don't tell us only after first
piling up another 9 trillion in national
debt those who pay no federal income
taxes at all half of all Americans can
somehow be promised an income tax cut we
are lectured that prior reckless federal
spending and borrowing got us into this
mess and it did but an Orwellian faction
now we are told that more federal
spending and more boring will get us out
of it when reality bothers us we invent
euphemisms borrowing trillions of
dollars to spend money that we do not
have is called stimulus not going into
even bigger debt or simply printing more
paper money language becomes too based
so promiscuously we throw around a
trillion
dollars here a trillion dollars there
the more that we do that the notion of
billions is reduced to near pocket
change
when Americans turn to their political
parties for answers they're even more
confused populist Democrats in Congress
took more Wall Street money than did
most pro-business Republicans and the
list of big state liberals who cheated
or avoided taxes they wanted to raise on
others is astounding so often the worst
offenders are precisely those with the
most executive and legislative
responsibility for a very system of tax
enforcement but conservative Republicans
during the Bush administration ran out
the debt and increased federal spending
far more to the Liberals under Bill
Clinton a Republican president has not
balanced a budget since the white
eisenhower did it over a half-century
ago
abroad things are even more surreal in
this year 2009 an Iranian president and
the United Nations conference on racism
let's lose a racist flurry against
democratic Israel we are warned that we
must be careful not to associate radical
Islam that fuelled the September 11
attacks with terrorists and terrorism
instead we are advised that we should
worry more about returning American
veterans who fought terrorists as
potential terrorists the word terrorism
itself is felt now to be hurtful so our
director of Homeland Security suggests
that we call it the morally neutral
man-made catastrophe when our president
references the 19th and 20th centuries
he apologizes for American sins that
stays silent about the United States
defeating Nazis fascist Japanese
militarists and Soviet communists the
world hears contrition about the
Americans dropping the bomb to end World
War two but never remorse from those
responsible today for Darfur Grozny or
Tibet much less how we should have
stopped the Japanese Imperial military
from killing more thousands of innocent
Asians every day so in this year 2009
the United States and Nina indeed the
world at large has lost its bearings but
in the challenging era such as this it
is vital that you piu before me
do not lose yours what then are the
familiar landscapes the voices in your
head
graduates of 2009 the knowledge you have
stockpile to see not just you but all of
us who need you so much through these
rough times ahead learn from this
landmark year 2009 that the unbelievable
can become the ordinary and a blink of
an eye that what is guaranteed can
become uncertain and that conventional
wisdom can easily prove to be ignorant
classical education reverence for family
and custom appreciation of our country's
constitution and the past sacrifices of
our ounds ancestors in times of want and
war these along state constant in times
like this when Lehman Brothers and GM
did not remember always the ancient
wisdom of moderation and the dangers of
utopianism we need not be perfect to be
good Americans brave men can battle the
avatars of the seventh century in the
Hindu Kush and can defeat them and can
save civilization from their mayhem and
they can do without having to read them
their Miranda rights
so keep some perspective as a Romans who
sighed sumos hominis nan de we're just
mortals we're not gods understand that
you stand on the shoulders of giants
I knew the class of 2009 or nothing if
you do not acknowledge the work of
others who rest in our graveyards learn
of those who died on Okinawa respect the
memory of those who fought at Gettysburg
connect the sacrifices of those who were
blown up at the Moose our
gone with your present freedom not just
on veterans or memorials days but daily
hourly as part of the voices in your
head that make you what you are no sin
is as great as that of ingratitude and
we the most wealthy and leisure
generation in American history
oh the most to those who are most
certainly not watch the wrath of nemesis
the universal power that seeks out the
powerful and the prideful at the moment
of the triumph only to destroy them for
their vanity and arrogance you the Wiz
mathematicians of this graduating class
mow your lawn before you enter college
you the concert level of the end
violinist help your mother iron the
family clothes before you go off to the
conservatory you the scholarship
football player don't be afraid to climb
up with on the ladder with your father
to mend the govern the gutter before you
head to practice ground yourself in
other words with material reality in
these trying times that are upon us and
when all those whom you thought were
rich and powerful desert you and at
times many of them will do just that you
will have your hands your work ethic
your childhood friends that you met at
Hillsdale and your families to remain
with you and they will this country has
had years of rage and decision seminal
years 1776 1861 1917 1929 1941 1968 2001
months that turn the country upside down
sometimes what followed these eventful
moments was further catastrophe but
sometimes just sometimes better times
ensued from the our terrible year of
ordeal so it is with this pivotal year
2009 in which you graduates leave
Hillsdale take up this opportunity learn
from it and use what you've learned here
in tiny Hillsdale to serve us in an
enormous but now troubled America who
needs you more than ever thank you and
good afternoon